und
der film eine schöne innere sonne
gewinnt wahrscheinlich den preis für den
alle in dem nächsten deutschen filmtitel
er heißt auf französisch tatsächlich so
die amerikaner haben es besser
die können let the sunshine in draus
machen
bei uns heißt halt so arbeiten sollten
abhalten sich anzugucken er ist nämlich
wirklich eine der allerschönsten filme
dieses jahres und ich bin wahnsinnig
froh dass er in die deutschen kinos
kommt endlich kann ich gedacht ich würde
meine frau niemals verlassen
du bist bezaubernder wenn meine frau ist
außergewöhnlich dahinter verbirgt sich
die geschichte einer frau gespielt von
der wirklich in diesem film grandiosen
goalie edwin ob die für mich da nicht
immer so die grandiose französische
schauspielerin ist sondern mir in vielen
firmen ausgeweitet auf die nerven geht
habe ich hier spielt sie eine malerin
eine unabhängige starke frau die auch
ihre angezogen ist immer so wenn die
schwarze auch wenn die stiefel und
shorts und also sehr körperbetont
lustbetont auch angezogen ist und die
durch paris zieht auf der suche nach
einem mann ist vielleicht gar nicht das
richtige aber doch noch mal nach diesem
großen gefühl weil sie das den eindruck
die große furcht hat möglicherweise sei
ihr liebesleben an ein ende gekommen
allein bei dem gedanken dass ein
drecksack ist wenn ich schon gekommen
oder ich habe ihn mir mit einer nutzer
vorgestellt oder auch mit seiner frau
und sie realisiert und wir natürlich als
zuschauer dass die schere zwischen dem
was sie bei den männern sucht und dem er
sie findet immer weiter
auseinanderklafft
und es ist einerseits natürlich komisch
andererseits ist es auch sehr traurig
und am nächsten morgen hatte ich das
gefühl unglaublich glücklich zu sein und
ich hatte mein leben so was und am
morgen danach habe ich das komplette
gegenteil ich bin alle leute sollten das
gucken man sagt ja immer das
französische kino hat auch bei
schwerwiegenden fragen und die frage
nach der echten liebe ist ja doch eine
sehr ernste dass das französische kino
diese leichtigkeit hat und es ist ein
klischee geworden aber hier ist es auch
es ist ein etwas wunderbar schweben dass
dieser film und das liegt daran dass
erklärte nie mit kristin um grob die mit
ihrem einnahmen das drehbuch geschrieben
hat die französische autorin eine
frauenfigur entwickelt haben gemein
geben auch praktiziert ich komme gerade
aus brasilien und hatte wahnsinnige
lustig zu finden geht nicht um alter es
geht nicht darum dass sie ihre
unabhängigkeit aufgibt oder sogar nicht
sondern sie hat die drei möglichkeiten
und sie sind kleiner geworden aber jetzt
nicht wegen ihr sondern weil die sozial
so konditioniert sind und wo verlobte
von sozialhilfe
das weiß ich nicht hab ich ihn nicht
gefragt trifft ich mit jemandem aus der
szene sonst wird doch nie was der titel
das muss ich jetzt doch noch verraten
darf ich auch verraten der verdankt sich
einem ganz späten eintritt einer anderen
französischen film legende nämlich der
radio party ist wirklich so ein richtig
so ein blöder wahrsager der minicool
kommt und der sagt eben diesen nun das
höre ich versuche eine schönere sommer
zu schenken
das ist natürlich ein blöder kann ja aus
irgendeinem glückskeks eigentlich stammt
keiner könnte so einen satz sagen ohne
dass man irgendwie entweder brüllen
davonläuft oder sich vor lachen aber ich
hier ist es wirklich das - gefühle
wahrscheinlich hat er reicht
wahrscheinlich ist es war das kann ich
doch nicht locker